und zwar folgendes leute etwas glaubt
jetzt bekommen bei nur ein video
wenn haben sind wir kurz ich hab sie
gerade nicht gemacht deswegen überlegt
dazu zu machen
wir machen das video heute einfach mal
so heute gibt's neues video von mir ich
habe wirklich lange okay jetzt muss ich
kurz also traurige musik dankeschön
ich habe wirklich sehr lange überlegt ob
ich über dieses thema ein video machen
soll wisst ihr das ganze ist eigentlich
mega privat und es geht doch eigentlich
gar keinen was an
aber das muss jetzt einfach raus leute
ich traue mich das wirklich eigentlich
gar nicht zu sagen aber ich weiß nicht
in letzter zeit mehr ich das einfach
immer mehr
das beugt sich immer weiter auf es nun
immer weiter zu und zwar folgendes leute
sneaker sind für mich nicht einfach nur
sneaker sondern vielmehr ich mein schaut
euch doch mal dieses aussehen an
schaut euch diese form an da wird man am
liebsten direkt beim reinbeißen
man könnte fast sagen sneaker sind der
wichtigste bestandteil meines lebens
wäre jetzt mal spaß beiseite
ja ich finde in letzter zeit gibt es da
so eine entwicklung die vielleicht vor
allem durch youtube entsteht die meiner
meinung nach ein bisschen fragwürdig ist
und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht kommen
machst du darüber doch einfach mal ein
video der let's go also wie schon eben
gesagt ich glaube wirklich dass diese
entwicklung so zu 90 prozent wegen
youtube so abläuft wie sie abläuft weil
halt youtube da ist und dieses thema auf
youtube zurzeit so ist wie es ist
erstmal vorweg ich habe wirklich gar
nichts also wirklich wirklich gar nichts
überhaupt nichts gegen irgendwelche
julia deren konten zu 95 prozent aus
schulen oder sneakern bestätigt meint
wenn man spaß daran hat und wenn es dann
auch noch zieht würde ich wahrscheinlich
genauso machen ich meine das ist ja
perfekt und ich würde auch ganz offen
sagen ich finde es nica auch vor allem
in letzter zeit immer zunehmend
attraktiver und es ist halt bei mir auch
schon so
ich hole mir so alle ein bis zwei
monaten ein neues pass nica wenn es
heißt sogar passt und mir irgendwas
gefällt so vielleicht halt wie gesagt
ein zwei monate kommt dann mal was neues
dazu für 100 bis 200 euro oder so und
ich meine das ist im vergleich zu früher
schon extrem viel wenn ich mich so an
meine kindheit erinnere somit zwölf
jahren ich glaube da hatte ich so jedes
jahr ein neues paradox kennt ihr noch
diese georg so als wenn nicht ich mein
so das hat eigentlich so ihre kindheit
geprägt diese geox also wenn er georg
cirquent könnt ihr gerne dort nach oben
da lassen
georgs der schuh der atmet dritte dem
dem und jeder wollte jobs haben weil es
halt atmet keine ahnung wer staaten soll
aber geox hat geatmet digger aber ganz
ehrlich wenn ich mal so mein lebenslauf
betrachte dann fällt mir so einiges auf
ganz bitter wenn man cool wenn man cool
war dann war man cool wenn man mit zwölf
schon mal bier getrunken hat bei seinem
vater oder so und dann war man cool wenn
man eine hübsche freundin hatte oder
generell hübsche freundinnen hatte ist
für mich auch noch logisch dass kann ich
noch nachvollziehen aber ich glaube
heute ist man nur noch cool wenn man
fucking easy es für 1000 euro trägt so
wie ich jeden tag auf meiner youtube
startseite sehr schuhe schuhe für 1000
euro das im schule ok um ehrlich zu sein
ich finde diese idee es auch cool
attraktiv würde ich mir direkt holen
wenn sie jetzt sich 800 euro kosten
würde ich meine ich geb doch nicht 800
euro für schüler aus wenn ihm irgendwas
sponsoren will wright placement gerne
aber 800 euro für schuhe alter meiner
meinung nach gibt es genug schuhe die
deutlich geile aussehen als diese jesus
und dann vielleicht nur 200 euro kosten
ich meine das ist auch schon viel aber
ist es noch eher im rahmen als 800 euro
und dann stellt euch mal vor okay das
ist jetzt vielleicht weit her gegriffen
aber stellt euch vor jeder coole jesih
besitzer hätte sich anstatt 800 euro
schuhe nur 200 euro schuhe gekauft ich
glaube mit dem übrigen geld zu 600 euro
mal keine ahnung wie viele hieß es auf
der welt gibt könnte man schon einigen
menschen mit ziemlich große freude
bereiten das hört sich jetzt vielleicht
scheiße an so ich habe jetzt nur soll
ich selber machen so klar aber dass ich
finde ich ein gedanke wir hier
wir kümmern uns um schuhe und leute die
vielleicht acht stunden im flugzeug von
uns entfernt sitzen
die denken wenn dir das wissen würden
die würden denken was es mit den falsch
guckt euch bei uns an und guckt euch an
bei uns geht es darum irgend etwas zu
essen zu finden und bei euch geht es
darum das ist ehrlich so also ich will
es auch gar nichts gegen euch sein klar
unter euch wird wahrscheinlich auch ein
paar von diesen leuten geben aber in der
jugend nimmt das einfach immer mehr zu
coole schuhe zu haben so klar ist es
cool aber die leute dass das merkt man
wirklich krass die leute die teure
cooles niger haben werden automatisch
besser angesehen als die die keine
coolen sneaker haben sondern was wenig
anhaben so diese hohe klickzahlen auf
diesen videos die spiegeln ja eigentlich
nur diese menge an leuten wieder die
sich gerne wünschen solche jesus für 800
euro zu tragen aber leute ganz ehrlich
ihr seid nicht cooler wenn jetzt ein
paar jesus haft oder sonst war es keine
ahnung ob sinnvoll war hier über ein
video zwar von ob mein gedankengang
wieder ein paar leuten nicht gefällt
oder so aber ich finde ich mache mir so
was halt manchmal gedanken und seinen
gedankengang dann irgendwie auf youtube
zu präsentieren finde ich cool deswegen
ihr könnt ja mal schreiben sieht das
auch so wie ich oder bin ich dumm kann
ja auch sein aber ganz ehrlich was ich
noch mal zum abschluss sagen wollte so
ich finde diesen hype darum wirklich ein
bisschen fragwürdig meint einmal brutal
eure facebook timeline runter und ihr
werdet merken dass auf der welt wirklich
so viele menschen gibt die ganz andere
probleme haben als ich jetzt für 800
euro jesus zu kaufen oder irgendwelche
coole sneakers zu haben ich finde diese
sneaker kulig tragt ihr gerne aber mein
gott das sind schuhe das und schuhe ja
leute das war's mit diesem video wenn es
euch gefallen hat last gern jetzt nach
oben da wie gesagt schreibt eure meinung
dazu in die kommentare
würd mich wirklich sehr interessieren
solche videos so einfach mal über ein
thema zu philosophieren
manchmal finde ich cool in letzter zeit
macht mir mega bock deswegen wirklich
freuen wenn das cool bereich ankommt wir
sehen uns sonntag wieder glaube ich drei
leute schönen tag noch ps folgt auf
instagram da kommt coole sneakers uns